every single day I'm just thinking about
what's the one step I can take today
that's gonna help me move forward now
what I do do is I try to copy people in
other industries the things you want
will come to you when you're ready for
it hey guys welcome to another bow show
you know we do here you watch this all
the time we've interview the most
influential and innovative people on the
planet and today is no exception
I'm with one of my favorite people on
the internet because this guy is
exploding on with Lois house how are you
brother
my man appreciate you good to see ya
Lois is the founder of school of
greatness he's a best-selling New York
Times author he's just launched his
awesome new Facebook TV show inspiring
life with Lois house which you've got to
check it out the first episode was the
power of forgiveness with Gabby
Bernstein man it must be so exciting to
be you right now
it's a lot of fun man you know it's fun
when you have a dream and an idea and a
vision and you're able to make it come
to reality and there's so many moving
parts you know the bigger the dream
there's usually more people involved in
making it happen I've had to really
learn how to be able to connect with
lots of different personalities lots of
individuals executives for this specific
show to make it actually happen and
there were a lot of hiccups and
obstacles along the way that potentially
didn't make it happen but I'm glad we're
here you've proven that you can make
dreams come true and we got a lot of
entrepreneurs on here and I think one of
the things that circles around their
heads is they love hearing from people
like yourself that what advice would you
give to someone who wants to who wants
to start this journey and who's a bit
scared because they're looking only at
the summit and realize oh my goodness
for me I had this dream 10 years ago I
was on my sister's couch broke it was
living off credit card debt student loan
debt I didn't have a job and I was on my
sister's couch for a year and a half and
I remember thinking myself one day I
just got done playing football
professional football and didn't have
any other real skills or back-up plan
and I didn't want to go work a job but I
didn't know how to make money so I was
just kind of stuck there in no-man's
land and I remember thinking to myself
one day I would love to be able to do
what Oprah and Ellen
these people do like it's so fun to
watch them just facilitate and ask what
she doesn't get the best out of people
what I've been able to do that that year
the next year there's no chance I
would've been able to do what I'm doing
now within the next couple of years I
didn't have the skills the experience
the practice reps to believe for myself
and it really took 10 years for me to
get to that place now I had lots of big
moments and dreams that did happen along
those years so it wasn't just like a
10-year grind and nothing happened I
think you take every year with
milestones and every year I would try to
do two or three big dreams or big goals
and make them happen and in the journey
and in the process of of that pursuit
you're learning you're achieving you're
developing you're building relationships
yeah I mean I made so many mistakes and
I just continue to grow and I think as
long as you say I am focused on a growth
mindset I'm focused on continual growth
learning putting myself out there in big
ways then you're setting yourself up for
big opportunities you hit on something
there which i think is so important that
you're gonna make mistakes things are
gonna happen your your big plan that
you've invested what little money you
have is gonna fall through and are there
any pitfalls that you had along the way
that you could be like look you're gonna
make your own mistakes but if you can
that's just something to avoid let maybe
following the crowd or something like
that yeah I think being your unique self
and not trying to copy anyone in your
space is definitely key now what I do do
is I try to copy people in other
industries I look for people in the
sports world I look for people in the
music world
I'm like oh it's really cool how they
shared their message that way or their
branding or their photography or their
videos and I try to incorporate you know
I think steal like an artist is the book
I try to I try to incorporate you know
mimicking things that I'm inspired by
outside of my industry and bringing it
into my industry and then then I look
like I'm fresh and innovative right so I
try to do that something I learned early
on was to run my own race and there are
many times when I was like oh this
person's doing this I should do that and
this person's doing this project I
should pursue that
I mean I remember one day a few years
ago I was like man I met this guy who
was running a magazine a digital
magazine I was like man this guy's
killing it and how cool is this and I
was like I'm gonna do a magazine and I
literally spent six months of my life so
much energy with my team and so much
money designing this Matt is in a
developing and we did our first three
issues and we never even put anything
out there because I was just like what
are we doing what am I doing this for
why am I doing this so constantly asking
yourself why am i doing something that
I'm doing is it because I want to do it
or because I feel like I'm supposed to
do it running my own race and then one
of the big things that I would say
that's a lesson I've learned is to not
be reactive to people's comments or
feedback or information even this talk
show that I launched a couple days ago
right we're getting you know over a
million views already you know which is
hard to do on a 18 minute video on
Facebook we're getting lots of comments
and engagement and some of my influencer
friends right are just automatically
sending me feedback you know here's what
I love about it but here's what you
could do differently in here's we can do
better blah blah blah and as opposed to
reacting or defending myself and just
like awesome thank you for the feedback
and I used to always defend myself
constantly back in the day online when
someone would leave a comment or
something nasty I would try to defend
myself and now I just take it as okay
this is great information feedback and
I'll see if I kind of pull in the next
time so don't react to people's comments
the best you can something that you've
put on the map in this kind of sphere of
the world especially for the demographic
is it's okay to be vulnerable and your
mask of masculinity but a phenomenal
book it was needed in this time more
than ever and what you're saying they're
taking taking on stuff and just letting
it sit and being vulnerable because
peoples are only doing their best even
if they're being venomous they're trying
their best but I think your dog wouldn't
say you're the flag holder but I'd say
you're one of the pioneers who's gone
into this to say okay it's okay to be
vulnerable it's okay to be forgiving of
yourself and healing yourself so I think
it's really important that you guys on
this one
this video understand that and although
I'm not trying to plug the book it's an
incredible book because it takes you
through a journey of the masks and it's
really important I learnt a lot there it
is guys I'll plug it myself there you go
you know what every time I buy one your
books a friend of mine sees it on my
shelf and goes can I borrow it
yes I've gotten through ten I like it
you should buy more just keep them on
the shelf yeah but another thing that's
amazing about you is people a lot of the
people that you speak to I'm very
fortunate now to be able to interact to
it and everyone I speak to loves you man
it's there's a lot alert people like Mel
Robbins and Gary Vee and stuff and I
started my own channel a long time ago
because I wanted to be surrounded by
better people and it worked my life
transformed so having a mastermind of
these people not on tap but surrounding
would you say that has a big influence
in your life it's a game changer I mean
it's unbelievable because I'm looking at
my wall right here I'll put the video
for a second it's like my wall of
greatness of like just some of the
people I've interviewed right and every
time I look over there I'm like man I
can't believe these people I've had not
only the chance to interview but a lot
of home on the constant text phone call
with I've meet them up with them all the
time you know I'm constantly supporting
them and what they're going through but
they're also just helping me and they're
just been great friends some more than
others obviously and and I just reflect
on it and it's like there's so much
wisdom on these individuals and there's
so much goodness inside of them and the
moments I share with them the
experiences the the relationships I have
are just for me it's priceless so even
if the show you know wasn't doing as
well as it was just to have access to
the people I've met and to be able to
connect with them it's it's a game
changer well it changed my life I did an
interview with you a year ago I was just
starting out and I've got I've got this
fearless mentality I'm just gonna dive
in I don't care if I don't have the
equipment I don't care if I'm just gonna
start and we had a small chat after it
that I have recorded on my own thing we
never broadcasted though and it was I
asked you for advice I'm not afraid to
ask beer and you gave me some real to
the point blunt advice and I took on
board what you said
and I just ran with it and I did
everything i could have graded my stuff
I got my pitches right I worked my ass
off and now look we're like we got 1.4
million subs on here it's amazing and
that's just from that so from my heart
Thank You Man four horsemen being
vulnerable to allowing people into your
world so I know a lot of people in this
industry they kind of they get
protective in a way because they feel
like they've earned it and now you got
to get to their level so yeah you're
opening the kind of the doors for that
but thank you
you've just as you've launched your TV
show I just love to talk about it some
more and just kind of what do you got
going on with it now what's your big
vision and what else are you doing
because I know you're not you're never
doing just one thing yeah the show kids
got five episodes it launches once a
week for five weeks and so I'm I'm
focused in the moment on you know
talking about that sharing it and and
following through I think a lot of
people will come out with something and
they don't follow through to the end you
know they have a book that comes out
they have a podcast that comes out of
course but then they never fully they'll
get excited for a few days but then
something happens or there's a hiccup or
a challenge or it's not going the way
they want and they kind of like slowly
die off and go to the next thing I
always have things in the pipeline but
there's always big things happening in
the moment so I'm focused on giving my
full effort to this you know launch over
the next five weeks and I've also got a
big event happening in early October so
in a couple months I've got a big
conference in Columbus Ohio that my team
is working behind the scenes on that as
well so we've got that and those are the
two main things except for a documentary
that I was filming for the whole last
year that we just finished and now we're
taking it out but vision for me is to
have it on Netflix to have them putting
it in the front and playing the trailer
for everyone right when they show up
around the world and in connecting with
people there but we're about to take it
out and start shopping it as well if
there's anyone I know can do it it's you
my friends so just hearing you speak and
hearing what you're doing I know it's
gonna inspire a lot of people on here to
start their own journeys maybe not
through doing a YouTube channel or doing
but their own business and stuff so
there's traits that I can already see
that you're talking about you follow
through to the end you're disciplined
you're not afraid to try new things
and failed it's fantastic would you say
there's any hay use no words success
habits is there something that you do
and you go this is these are my
benchmarks for what I have to do in
order to be Lewis house mmm
I have to be myself and again not try to
do what everyone else is doing but try
to do what fuels my heart I think a lot
of people get caught up in starting a
business or something because they see
that it's good money or they see that
other people are doing it or there's a
great space but if this doesn't fuel
your heart if it doesn't excite you as
it doesn't make you excited every single
day to do it even if you weren't getting
paid then when you're not making money
and it gets hard you're gonna give up
eventually
so you got to find a way that you got to
figure out the lifestyle for me it's
always building the lifestyle first I
think in the business around the
lifestyle that's why I call myself a
lifestyle entrepreneur because it's like
what's the life I want to live
what's the feelings I want to have
whether people want to spend time with
the conversations things like that and
then how can I make money around the
thing I love or the thing that excites
me or the thing the lifestyle that I
have and for me personally that's just
how my personality works I just enjoy
that I know that if I was doing
something that I didn't enjoy as much I
wouldn't be as I'm gonna be a happy as
happy of a person I'd be kind of
frustrated I think and there are times
when we're gonna need to do things that
we don't want to do you know for years I
did things that I didn't want to do to
to make money to have the resources so
that I can go pursue my own thing so I'm
not ignorant to the fact that you may
spend years doing things that isn't
exactly what you want but it's gonna
give you that skills the tools the
resources to start pursuing that even
more well I know for me it shocked my
partner recently because I said I don't
know how to sell it's a skill that I've
not learned and we're doing a lot of
stuff with a towards getting grant
cardone and I was like you know what I'm
gonna take a cold call selling job and
they're just shocked and I went in the
deep end and it's one of the greatest
experiences because there's a skill that
I've learned that I can translate into
other things similar to like you looking
in other industries and it's not
moving on here to be a Salesman but your
delivery how the human mind where it's
fascinating wow that's great man I'm
never mind you're just gonna dive in
life's way too short that's it that's it
but on this channel as well we all have
a word that Evan Evans one word is
believe he lives that's these kind of
credo Minds incredible like I want to do
incredible things I want to meet
incredible people I just want an
incredible life would you have a word
that you feel embodies who you are
just that you go yeah that's me freedom
freedom to pursue the dreams you have
freedom to be your unique self freedom
to live this life the exact way you want
it that's so good well we got some
amazing answers on here but freedom man
you've it's it's very powerful
liberating thing that I think we all
need and I think we're there's this I
think the social media culture as well
people are getting a bit caught up in
comparing themselves to other people
it's why recently I I just shaved my
head for fun I did it cuz why not and
why not yeah nothing changed in the
world the world didn't stop because I've
always been kind of I need to make sure
my hair is good now that's great man
like you know the nice next thing next
thing you need to do is shave your beard
I know there's no face under here I
wonder I wonder if you could do it I
know I can do it but I gotta I know I
know in my heart of hearts oh I'm gonna
be on your channel soon because I've
pretty interesting story myself how I
got to where I am in life and I'll tell
you that day why I woke up one day white
like I've got white hairs and that does
overnight stress it was incredible time
Wow wouldn't change it for the world but
I think I just want to know right now if
you want to tell the people what your
Dukes I know you've got your mastermind
that's going online a lot of people are
interested in that we put out small
thing people are also interested in your
30 day book course your Instagram stuff
where can they go to check you out for
that yeah check it out lewis howes calm
for all my information obviously I've
got my school greatest podcast which is
thing I do every single week or
interviewing people and and and really
connect with people around the world
there inspire life on Facebook you just
type in inspiring life
with lewis howes and you'll see the
channel watch the episode share it with
a friend we've got our mastermind and
all the other stuff but you can check it
out at lewis howes comm and one thing
that your fans are really interactive
they're amazing guys so a lot of them
have jumped and come and found out who I
was because I put some hashtags and
stuff and they're interested while I'm
doing and they're so supportive so I
think for this generation you're doing
an incredible thing and thank you I
can't wait to see what you're gonna be
doing in five years ten years I know
you've got your vision and it's nice to
be a part of this so from myself and
from Evan just thank you so much for
everything you're doing for people
you've you probably have saved more
lives than you'll ever know and you made
people feel good about themselves
because in this day and age we need it
more than ever so thank you man
guys I'm hope he took something away
from this this was a really just I
wanted you guys to see someone who is
living his dream is still dreaming and
has come from nearly nothing to create
the life of his dreams yeah and I was
just gonna finish with saying you know
every single day I'm just thinking about
what's the one step I can take today
that's gonna help me move forward
progress is more important than
perfection and a day where you're not
progressing in something whether you're
taking that sales call training you know
cold cold calling training it's like
what how am I gonna progress from the
day before whether you're looking to
build your social media following how am
I gonna progress with the type of
content I create with how I'm engaging
with people you know if you're launching
a course or a business or a product or
something what's the step I'm gonna do
that's going to move the vision forward
and every day I'm just focused on what's
the thing that's gonna help me move
forward as opposed to do nothing now of
course here to take vacation days you're
to recover you relax all those things
it's great but in general the day to day
figure out what the big two or three
things are that you want to achieve for
that year for this year for the next 12
months and then break it down what's the
daily step that I can take that's gonna
give me one step closer and at the end
of the year you're gonna see yourself
achieving a lot of things in year after
year
like wow look at how far I've come and
so I might have a five or ten year
vision of where I want to be the things
I'd like to be creating at those moments
but I'm also really enjoying every
single day and the process and when I
put value into my process value into
those every interview and the
interactions and the relationships I
build those moments it doesn't frustrate
me that I don't have the biggest talk
show in the world or something yet
because I get to still build
relationship and connect with people and
help people through my message my
audience take it one day at a time don't
try to get there too fast you can try to
accelerate it and find the mentors and
get the right information but the things
you want will come to you when you're
ready for it so what are the things you
need to do to get ready for the things
you want guys this is a wise gentleman
listen to him he knows what he's talking
about there's no script there sit got
Lois thank you so much for giving us
your time on here and we are so excited
for people to take away from this if
you're watching this video get out your
pen and paper take some notes on it what
did you learn from it what did you like
what didn't you like what are your
parallels so from us over here the bow
shown from Lewis thank you so much for
tuning and we'll see you for another bow
show soon Lewis thank you very much
appreciate it buff raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
passion not one drop of most self-worth
depends on Europe it's something surreal
if you want to learn more from Lewis I
highly recommend the top ten rules video
we did on him the link is right next to
me continue to believe and I'll see you
there
when I'm not excited about something
then I want to give up or I don't want
to do it yeah I want to go back to
thinking about my dream I've always
wanted to be a symbol of inspiration